merci Nadia solo de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure et
sénatrice centrices de la Nièvre
président du groupe d’amitié France
Ukraine ici au Sénat va bien sûr
longuement parler du débat sur l'Ukraine
qui avait lieu hier dans l'hémicycle
mais d'abord un mot sur Emmanuel Macron
qui a dit qu'il fallait protéger les
plus faibles en s'attend de crise que
nous sommes en train de traverser il a
tracé le cap fait quelques annonces
est-ce que vous avez compris où il
voulait en venir est-ce que le cap est
le bon pour vous écoutez je vous dis
toute la vérité j'ai pas écouté voilà
j'étais sérieuse en effet ça c'était en
même temps c'était un
intervenait en même temps donc
évidemment je vais regarder en replay
aujourd'hui une petite réaction
peut-être marginale moi je suis un petit
peu choquée parce que le Président de la
République continue à annoncer des
mesures qui sont pas voûtées et il
fonctionne comme ça et je trouve que
c'est non respectueux du travail du
Parlement moi dans ma petite commune
quand j'étais mère on annonçait pas les
mesures tant qu'elles étaient pas votées
par le conseil municipal donc voilà ce
serait bien d'attendre que les mesures
voter avant de dire que c'est gravé dans
le marbre après migration notamment il a
dit qu'elle avait un travail avec les
députés les sénateurs oui bon ben
maintenant voilà c'est maintenant on
travaille beaucoup plus avec les
sénateurs donc c'est bien je m'en
félicite bon après sur le fait de
protéger les plus faibles c'est vrai que
dans un département comme le mien on a
des entreprises qui souffrent énormément
qui sont très très inquiets explosion
des factures d'énergie mais en péril des
entreprises florissantes et là il a
étendu de bouclier tarifaire pour les
entreprises qui n'étaient pas concernées
jusque là certaines PME mais aussi
certaines catégories
socioprofessionnelles les boulangers les
agriculteurs qui la cité ça c'est une
bonne chose on imagine que ça dans votre
département c'était attendu j'ai une
alerte très forte aussi sur les bouchers
charcutiers qui concerne beaucoup
d'énergie et on a des très belles
entreprises on peut pas se permettre de
les perdre donc ça c'est bien cette
extension du boucle
sur sur la réforme des retraites alors
il maintient évidemment le fait qu'il y
aura une réforme des retraites mais il a
ouvert un peu la porte il dit ça peut
être 64 ans au lieu de 65 à condition
qu'on travaille sur le nombre de
trimestres cotisés ça ça peut être un
bon compromis pour vous
pour moi je trouve que c'est prématuré
pour pour le dire j'ai pas de position
franchement après c'est sur le principe
de cette réforme des retraites on sait
qu'elle est nécessaire ça c'est vraiment
je rends mage à son courage parce que
c'est pas facile par contre j'imagine
même pas comment on peut discuter une
réforme des retraites dans le contexte
actuel c'est j'appréhende vraiment cette
période donc c'est pas le bon calendrier
à faire ça en janvier c'est pas le bon
mot et en même temps j'ai rien à dire
parce qu'il faut le faire donc voilà
c'est c'est compliqué on est vraiment
dans une impasse sur ce sujet là je
pense que je ferai preuve de de
discipline sur les déserts médicaux
c'est un sujet ça aussi que vous
connaissez bien que vous suivez bien
dans votre département on va l'écouter
justement ce qu'il a dit parce que pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux il a
fait une annonce elle concerne les
médecins retraités
donc on va faire quelque chose de très
simple qu'on a travaillé avec nos
députés notre ministre de la Santé la
première ministre tous les médecins qui
arrivent à la retraite
on va leur permettre de prendre la
retraite mais au premier jour de leur
retraite de pouvoir continuer leur
activité et de garder tous les revenus
qui sont les leurs pour eux sans payer
de cotisations retraite nouvelles et
donc de pouvoir accumuler votre retraite
à taux plein quand vous y avez droit et
en plus de ça va vos salaires et vous ne
payez plus les droits après donc c'est
un vrai changement de vie
alors moi je trouve ça formidable parce
que je défends cet amendement tous les
ans depuis 2018 je me fais autoquer donc
là c'est bien le travail que les députés
mais moi je m'en félicite c'est vrai
qu'on parle beaucoup des jeunes médecins
et heureusement qu'on allait mettre sa
retraités on a dans nos territoires des
médecins qui travaillent jusqu'à 70 75
ans tout simplement parce qu'il ne
souhaite pas abandonner leurs clientèle
alors pour l'instant ils peuvent déjà
être accumulés l'emploi retraite sauf
qu'il commence il continue à cotiser
pour leur retraite et ils sont plafonnés
dans leurs revenus donc il faut
évidemment des plafonner tout ça et ce
qui change il y a plus de cotisations
mais je vous dis je le défends depuis
2018 et chaque fois on retombe en me
disant il y en a bien assez comme ça
pour les médecins retraité donc bon je
le félicite voilà c'est formidable
sur il a répété à plusieurs reprises
qu'il fallait que l'organisation sur les
déserts médicaux se fasse à l'échelle de
chaque territoire pour vous aussi il
faut une organisation différenciée en
fonction du territoire sur cette
question oui et puis même en fonction de
chaque médecin parce que finalement on
n'arrête pas de parler de prix mais il
faut arrêter avec les prix mais il faut
simplement les médecins ces gens comme
les autres ils viennent s'installer et
vivre dans un territoire où ils vont
être bien s'épanouir personnellement et
professionnellement donc il faut trouver
les les moyens pour que s'épanouissent
dans leur travail qu'il soit pas en
burn-out au bout de deux ans enfin c'est
valable pour toutes les professions de
santé toutes les professions en général
d'ailleurs il y a une autre mesure qui a
été proposée par le gouvernement et
également par le groupe les républicains
ici au Sénat l'initiative de Bruno
Retailleau c'est de faire une quatrième
année de médecine pour les internes de
médecine générale et que ils aient
justement dans ces territoires sous
dotés ça c'est une bonne chose alors
c'était très mal présenté parce que le
titre initial c'était de dire qu'on les
envoyait dans le désert alors je trouve
ça scandaleux d'envoyer dans le désert
des jeunes qui donnent déjà un temps
considérable je crois que ça
heureusement qu'ils sont là pour faire
tourner les CHU il est hors de question
d'envoyer des jeunes dans le désert par
contre qu'ils aient une année qui serait
une quatrième année de spécialisation de
même que pour les autres spécialités
pendant laquelle nous on met des moyens
suffisants pour les
lancer dans la vie active en étant des
docteurs junior pendant une année
intermédiaire mais par contre avec des
bons maîtres de sage que ce soit bien
encadré qu'on fasse pas n'importe quoi
d'ailleurs moi je me souviens d'avoir
parlé avec des internes en médecine qui
était tout à fait d'accord si si c'est
bien fait voilà maintenant voilà les
fois les dans les syndicats les gens
changent mais il y a un an ou deux ils
étaient d'accord c'est pas exactement la
bonne voiture soit pour eux si si c'est
une très bonne mesure mais pas de la
manière dont elle est faite et après
quand il passe un an dans un territoire
soudoté on va dire maintenant c'est sous
dotée partout mais à une année
intermédiaire ça peut leur donner envie
de s'installer donc c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant c'est une année on peut leur
faire aimer les gens tout simplement de
chez nous voilà donc c'est une bonne
mesure mais qu'on leur présente pas
comme ça puis on envoie pas des jeunes
dans le désert
qui est le président du groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée nationale donc membre de la
majorité il dit les déserts médicaux
c'est un carburant pour l'extrême droite
vous êtes d'accord avec ça dans mon
département ou qui était historiquement
socialiste maintenant ça vaut beaucoup
RN c'est le sujet c'est l'accès aux
soins c'est la santé et je voulais aussi
redire que chez nous c'est pas le désert
il faut arrêter de parler comme ça faut
qu'on reste ce mot oreille le désert non
mais est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
c'est un carburant c'est le sujet de
colère tel que c'est ça donc c'est une
urgence
on en a assez on est oublié on va parler
de ce qui s'est passé hier soir dans
l'hémicycle puisque effectivement on
n'avait pas su manuel Macron puisque
vous étiez une séance puisqu'il y avait
un débat quasi au même moment débat sur
la guerre en Ukraine et ses conséquences
pour la France en présence d'Elizabeth
bandes on va tout ça avec Marion Vigreux
[Musique]
Jean Marion bonjour Oriane bonjour
vous avez donc suivi hier soir ce débat
au Sénat sur la guerre en Ukraine et ses
conséquences pour la France oui cela
fait 8 mois maintenant que le conflit a
débuté c'était le 24 février dernier et
dès le début de son discours Elisabeth
borne a rappelé que cette guerre était
illégale et que l'Ukraine avait le
soutien à plein et entier de la France
écoutez-la ce sujet
là où l'armée ukrainienne progresse la
libération s'accompagne de la découverte
de massacres et de charniers comme à
bout de chat au printemps et plus
récemment à is Youm ce sont des actes
choquants révoltants monstrueux ce sont
des violations barbares des lois de la
guerre la Russie devra en réponse
nous sommes déterminés à ce que les
crimes commis par la Russie soient
documentée punais jugé et puni quant aux
conséquences du conflit pour notre pays
on peut en citer deux évidemment
l'inflation avec l'augmentation à des
prix de l'énergie mais aussi
l'investissement militaire de la France
et sur la défense justement la première
ministre a fait le point sur la
situation opérationnelle évoquant la
contre-offensive ukrainienne de ces
dernières semaines mais rappelant aussi
que le conflit allait durer
malgré les fragilités russes nous
croyons pas un instant que la fin des
combats soit proche
la mobilisation russe apportera de
nouveaux soldats sur le front
l'arrivée de nouvelles troupes russes en
Biélorussie nous préoccupe
collectivement la Russie est prête à
tout et ce n'est pas sur un champ de
bataille mais autour d'une table de
négociation que nous trouverons une
issue à cette guerre et Marion
Elisabelle born a également évoqué le
soutien militaire de la France oui avec
la livraison d'armes qui a commencé dès
le mois de février puis de canon César
de véhicules blindés et dans la dans les
semaines à venir de système entière la
France qui accueillera également en 2000
militaires Ukrainiens pour les former et
qui va mettre à disposition de l'Ukraine
un fond de 100 millions d'euros pour lui
permettre de commander directement du
matériel militaire auprès des
industriels de défense française la
France aide l'Ukraine donc mais renforce
aussi sa présence dans les pays de
l'OTAN déployant des forces en Roumanie
en Lituanie et en Estonie madame la
sénatrice la France a longtemps été
accusée de ne pas livrer suffisamment
d'armes à l'Ukraine dites-vous désormais
à la lumière des éléments transmis hier
par Elisabeth borne
politiques la même remarque a été faite
c'est-à-dire que non les informations ne
sont pas très précises on n'est pas en
capacité de donner un avis on a tous
fait remarquer que on nous dit on livre
des canons Césars en fournit une
quantité indéterminée de 6 ou de ça on a
on a aucune information réellement très
précise on peut donner des informations
précises c'est une guerre est-ce que le
gouvernement peut le mettre sur la place
publique des informations aussi
spécifiques que quel type d'armes quelle
quantité d'armes pour vous alors on
n'est pas la place publique on est le
Parlement donc je pense que c'est à dire
que même par exemple vous en avez parlé
Christian Cambo j'imagine qu'il préside
la commission des forces armées et de la
défense ici au Sénat même cette
commission n'a pas les informations
alors j'en ai pas parlé avec Christian
Cambon mais avec des membres de mon
groupe qui font partie de de ces
commissions ou non ils arrivent pas à
avoir une information très précise donc
en effet pas dans des instances pas lors
d'un débat public mais il pourrait y
avoir je pense
un petit noyau de personnes en effet la
Commission à la défense où il y ait des
informations importantes ou alors en
moins des montants parce que on est dans
des débats budgétaires je pense que de
dire combien ça coûte ça dérangerait pas
beaucoup le Kremlin c'est pas
stratégique donc au moment de de débats
budgétaires on aimerait tout simplement
tout en étant favorable en soutenant le
gouvernement bah savoir précisément
combien ça coûte parce qu'on nous dit ça
coûte beaucoup ou pas beaucoup c'est
c'est très vague dans on est et on
aurait besoin d'en savoir plus de
transparence et de communication
qu'en bon c'est également à l'armée du
fait qu'avec ces livraisons notamment à
celle de canon César on allait je cite
dépouillé l'armée française et qu'il
allait donc falloir renforcer
sérieusement la projet de loi de
programmation militaire vous le pensez
également alors le ministre nous a dit
ensuite que c'était des ragots des ondi
et qu'il fallait pas s'inquiéter bon
tout ça non je j'ai pas d'avis on n'est
pas on n'est pas très rassuré bon il
faut envoyer les armes après des ont été
passés pour remplacer ces armements mais
enfin aux autres bien qu'on fait pas un
cadre César en quelques semaines donc
voilà non il imagine qu'on n'est pas
dans une position florissante mais c'est
pareil on sait pas très bien on nous a
dit non tout va bien mais on sait pas
très bien alors plusieurs de vos
confrères sénateurs se sont également
inquiétés au sujet des conséquences du
conflit de la multiplication des
attaques cyber du développement de la
force Wagner de la guerre en
FORMATIONNELLE mais aussi de la menace
nucléaire et de l'impréparation des
populations civiles en cas d'attaque
enfin hier Elisabeth borne a également
rappelé que des négociations se
tiendront quand l'Ukraine le décidera
mais les communistes par la voix de
Pierre Laurent ont exhorté le
gouvernement à ne pas oublier la
nécessité d'un cesser le feu écouter le
nous pensons madame la ministre qu'il
faut avoir madame la Première ministre
qu'il faut avoir le courage de ne pas
abandonner l'exigence d'un cesser le feu
le plus rapide possible sur le front
dire cela scdo russe comme on l'entend
dire comme s'il s'agit d'accepter de
geler la situation sur la ligne de front
actuelle bien sûr que non dire cela
c'est demandé que dans la guerre la voix
de la paix et de la diplomatie ne
s'éteigne pas et qu'elle reprenne la
main au plus vite sans accepter le
terrible prix humain d'une amplification
de cette guerre une guerre à l'heure
qu'il est sans perspective de fond on le
voit les communistes mais ils ne sont
pas le seul à un demande le retour du
dialogue pour la paix faut-il
effectivement envisager une reprise
rapide des négociations surtout il faut
pas se l'interdire au motif que on
semblerait prorus parce que finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on cherche au bout est-ce
qu'on cherche une victoire militaire ou
est-ce qu'on cherche la paix voilà faut
juste se demander au stade où on en est
c'est quoi le but et vers quoi on va et
le but oui je pense que que c'est la
paix en effet il faut absolument rien
s'interdire pour aller vers la paix et
le fait de dire qu'on serait pro russe
en demandant à négocier c'est un peu
simple
est-ce que les Ukrainiens ils seraient
prêt à négocier tant que les troupes
russes sont dans leur pays les
Ukrainiens n'ont pas du tout l'air pré
négocié mais en même temps c'est ce
qu'on disait qui décide du tempo
maintenant il faut aussi bon voilà on
fournit des armes on met nos entreprises
en difficulté on les aide on les lâchera
pas on a été là du premier jour on a eu
constamment on peut avoir des exigences
aussi en disant que nous notre objectif
c'est la paix et puis ça veut dire que
la France elle doit pousser l'Ukraine
aussi à négocier pour vous ben oui ça me
choquerait pas oui oui il faut il faut
absolument voilà que maintenant on
arrive à enfin il faut surtout que la
France sache où elle va et en effet pour
tout le monde le but c'est la paix le
plus vite possible donc on va lui dire
ce qui dit que lui il négociera pas tant
Poutine est à la tête de la Russie pour
vous c'est une erreur pour moi je le
comprends en même temps quand on est
dans le conflit chaud et armé on voit
pas la même chose de la même manière
c'est évidemment compréhensible et il
n'est pas question non plus de leur
demander une reddition ou de baisser on
leur demande pas de rendre les armes
c'est pas ça mais on demande de
d'écarter aucun moyen d'arriver au plus
vite à la paix du point de vue ukrainien
comment les perçu sa tête de la France
est-ce que pour les Ukrainiens elle est
suffisante alors pour les Ukrainiens
elle est très importante moi j'ai eu
cette chance d'aller avec le président
Larcher en Ukraine au mois de juillet
c'était inoubliable on a eu un accueil à
la Rada c'était le temps le plus fort
ont vraiment des ovations bon moi ça m'a
arraché des larmes c'est vraiment
complètement bouleversant et surtout ne
nous lâchez pas ne nous lâchez pas ne
nous lâchez pas la main ne nous oubliez
pas donc c'est d'ailleurs un risque ça a
été dit aussi beaucoup c'est que
l'opinion publique française les
Français ils sont plein d'autres soucis
maintenant que cela c'est un petit peu
de de l'aide aux Ukrainiens donc voilà
il faut déjà si on arrive à maintenir ce
lien bien vivant et bien solide ce sera
une grande victoire mais ça c'est
important ce que vous dites que les
Français ils ont d'autres soucis ceux-là
c'est un peu de l'aide aux Ukrainiens
est-ce que vous craignez ça sur l'aide
est-ce que les Français disent à un
moment bon on les aide trop on risque de
dépouiller notre âme etc et deux sur les
sanctions est-ce que vous craignez aussi
que les Français disent les sanctions
d'accord mais nous la hausse des prix de
l'énergie on l'a subi et à un moment il
faut arrêter les sanctions alors oui oui
moi je humainement je le comprends
parfaitement je vous parlais des
bouchées charcutier tout à l'heure le
type a une super boîte qui bosse nuage
depuis des années et qu'à 18 salariés
qui va mettre la clé sous la porte parce
qu'il peut plus payer son gaz qui a été
multiplié par 6 à un moment donné il
trouve que c'est pas très juste de faire
faillite à se motif là mais par contre
en même temps j'ai entendu on a eu
Geoffroy de route des yeux qui est venu
à Nevers et quelques jours oui voilà
pardon le patron du Ménès et il disait
il faut passer des c'est très dur mais
il faut tenir de toute manière aussi la
stabilité politique d'un pays c'est
aussi ça qu'elle garant de la réussite
économique des entreprises donc si nous
aussi on bascule en le désordre le chaos
la tyrannie et bien nos entreprises s'en
sortiront pas bien non plus donc ça veut
dire que vous craignez pas de
retournement les opinion publique
française
c'est limite c'est limite il faut bon il
faut tenir mais c'est c'est là il se
passera quoi faire Emmanuel Macron
tiendra sur sa ligne ou selon vous
Emmanuel Macron sera obligé de suivre
son opinion ben je pense que Manuel
Macron fait prendre un certain courage
sur un certain nombre de sujets bon avec
lui on sait pas trop parce qu'ils
changent d'avis rapidement parfois donc
je sais pas mais j'espère mais
maintenant qu'on en est là on peut quand
même pas faire marche arrière on peut
pas céder devant dans les Russes donc il
faut quand même continuer les sanctions
et aller plus loin selon vos c'est ce
qu'attendre les Ukraine un mot sur ce
que disait Marion parce que vous êtes
aussi un quête de la présence russe en
Afrique notamment sur des milices du
groupe Wagner est-ce que là en Afrique
on est assez présent les français pour
contrer cette menace russe alors oui on
est on a un enjeu aussi parce que c'est
une guerre d'images on le sait on le
voit très bien tout le monde communiquer
énormément ce qui brouille d'ailleurs
l'information et c'est vrai que les
Russes paraissent en Afrique comme des
libérateurs etc il faut qu'on arrive il
faut qu'on arrive à contrer ça et que
nous on tenait dans notre groupe on en a
parlé collectivement on disait vraiment
il faut que la France arrive à faire
savoir quand même en Russie ce que font
réellement pardon en Afrique ce que font
réellement les Russes il faut rétablir
et il faut arrêter cette dessination
c'est important on va continuer à parler
de cette question de l'Ukraine merci
Marion à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
à parler d'Emmanuel Macron et des
réactions politiques que ça a suscité
évidemment ça sera le débat du club
merci Marion va continuer à parler de
l'Ukraine on va aller dans votre
département de la Nièvre à Nevers où on
retrouve Philippe de palme bonjour
Philippe merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteurs en chef du Journal du Centre
et on poursuit justement sur cette
question de l'Ukraine et vous allez nous
parler vous de l'accueil des réfugiés
Ukrainiens en France
oui bonjour
bonjour madame solo dans votre discours
d'hier vous soulignez l'invasion que
l'Ukraine a provoqué l'invention de
l'Ukraine renforcement de certaines
valeurs qui doivent rester un socle
commun vous évoquez ces élus et de nos
communes et les Français qui ont
ouvertement vers leur porte à des
familles dans la nièce se finit une
évidence très vite de nombreux
ukrainiens ont trouvé une terre
d'accueil dans votre département
quel constat faites-vous de cette
situation huit mois plus tard
bonjour d'abord je suis ravi de saluer
la Nièvre et Monsieur depal oui huit
mois après alors déjà la situation est
pas toujours connue de tout parce que il
y a eu plusieurs manières il y a des
gens qui sont arrivés par leur ils
avaient des contacts il y a eu des
initiatives généreuses avec des gens qui
sont allés les chercher tout simplement
qui ont ramené des familles c'est lourd
parce que il y a des gens qui sont qui
ont ouvert leur porte et puis huit mois
après on a toujours à la maison bon en
général les
Ukrainiens font preuve d'une énorme
résilience et ukrainienne et d'un
courage très grand l'ambassadeur de
pensée disait les Ukrainiens sont très
très résilients ces femmes ont plusieurs
enfants elles travaillent leur mari sont
au front et force le courage et
l'admiration par contre on n'a pas
forcément une vision très précise de
combien ils sont et où ils sont parce
qu'il y en a qui sont repartis ils ont
pas forcément prévenu vous n'arrivez pas
à savoir combien combien
c'est un peu à la louche c'est pas d'une
très grande précision bon par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est que hyper bosseur hyper
bosseur et ça c'est vraiment une très
belle et donne une très belle image on
peut je dis toujours ukrainien vous
pouvez être fier des femmes et des
enfants qui sont arrivés et les gosses à
l'école sont très bons élèves
sur un mot avant allez-y Philippe
continuez là-dessus sur cette question
du crâne vous avez d'autres questions
oui tout à fait dans ce même discours
vous rappelez en France la crise covid
avait accéléré la demande d'une
consommation alimentaire de proximité la
guerre et son cortège de difficultés
économiques pour les ménages les amène
désormais à privilégier l'alimentation à
moindre coût
le nième n'a pas été en retard sur ce
sujet une circule courbe ce sont
développés l'univers né en trouver une
autre manière de s'alimenter et y a-t-il
selon vous des dispositifs à mettre en
place pour conserver ce cercle vertueux
oui alors en effet dans la Nièvre on a
les circuits courts ça marche bien parce
qu'on a beaucoup de bons produits donc
c'est pratique de pouvoir
s'approvisionner en proximité les
dispositions d'abord je pense que les
collectivités devraient être exemplaires
c'est-à-dire que bien donner l'image que
l'alimentation c'est pas une variable
d'ajustement que la qualité c'est un
prix et que voilà même si la situation
est difficile il faut continuer à
proposer dans les crèches dans les
hôpitaux etc une alimentation de qualité
donc il faut déjà que les marchés
publics permettent de d'acheter au plus
près et dans les dans les circuits
courts et puis aussi il y a des
dispositions au niveau national il faut
absolument des clauses miroirs parce que
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vend chez nous et
dans les supermarchés des choses
des productions agricoles de mauvaise
qualité qu'on n'a pas le droit de
produire chez nous il vraiment que là on
y arrive il faut protéger nos
productions françaises parce que en plus
du reste cela si on ne si on détricote
ce qu'on vient de construire c'est
vraiment tellement dommage ça va à
l'encontre il faut aussi une très bonne
information pour le consommateur parce
que au final c'est lui qui est trompé
quand il achète un produit de mauvaise
qualité et que lui il croit de bonne foi
acheter quelque chose qui a été produit
en France ou dans de bonnes conditions
Philippe on va parler de votre une
maintenant parler de sobriété
énergétique la Question à la Une du
journal du centre ce matin c'est faut-il
avoir peur du noir
faut-il avoir peur de noir suite à cette
crise qui pousse les communes à faire
des restrictions énergétiques comme à
Nevers ou des 23 heures maintenant les
éclairages disparaissent et on se
retrouve un mois donc effectivement ce
geste permet de réaliser des économies
significatives sur la facture d'énergie
mais elle fait aussi ressurgir lancer le
peur du noir et les questions qui vont
avec ce que l'obscurité entraîne une
insécurité plus forte peut-être
provoquer plus d'accidents routiers et
donc nous avons tenté des réponses à ces
questions avec l'idée de des passionnés
de débat et sur ce sujet de l'énergie
j'aimerais poser une question à Madame
pensez-vous que ces économies
suffiront-elles à passer l'hiver afin de
ne pas retrouver
des difficultés aussi bien chez les
particuliers que dans les entreprises
parce que ça effectivement ça risque de
poser des problèmes oui oui évidemment
la situation est très très compliquée
alors vous dire que ça suffira non
évidemment ça suffira pas mais en même
temps si on se dit ça sans arrêt c'est
là que on passe sur les petits gestes du
quotidien c'est là que on laisse les
appareils sous tension etc voilà je
pense qu'en termes d'énergie il y a pas
de petit geste tout ce qu'on fait c'est
bien tout ce qu'on arrive à gratter
c'est bien après sur le fait d'avoir
peur du noir ce que la question se pose
le maire de Nevers il y a beaucoup de
merveaux qui sont posés à très longtemps
parce que moi je suis plus maire depuis
plus de 9 ans et déjà on était né à
10h30 ou 11 heures non seulement pour
faire des économies mais parce que ça
sert pas à grand chose puisque les
cambriolages pour leur majorité sont en
pleine journée et puis bon pour les
accidents l'accidentologie routière dans
les routes de campagne on est très
habitués à rouler sur des routes qui
sont pas allumées donc voilà la plupart
des communes rurales éteignent de depuis
longtemps alors peut-être qu'on se
couche plutôt
[Rires]
non non voilà je pense que oui oui c'est
pas très grave qui est plus d'éclairage
public à 23h il faut être raisonnable
mais par contre vous dire que ça suffira
à nos probablement non mais bon tout ce
qu'on fait c'est bien malgré tout c'est
symbolique vous voyez j'avais ce matin
un échange avec un ami qui habite à Kiev
qui me dit bon bah maintenant c'est
éteint toute la nuit mais c'est pas
grave bon voilà quand la situation est
grave que ce soit et à la nuit c'est
c'est vraiment mineur quand même merci
Philippe depal merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous on revoit à la une du
Journal du Centre faut-il avoir peur du
noir c'est la Question à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Nadia sur le
groupe d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]